Iran's leaders are reacting with anger
this morning the president Trump's
decision to withdraw the US from a
landmark nuclear deal lawmakers in
Iran's Parliament burned a paper
American flag and they chanted death to
America Iran's supreme leader called the
president's words yesterday's silly and
superficial and said mr. Trump you've
made a mistake in his White House
announcement President Trump called the
2015 deal horrible and disastrous his
decision to pull out threatens to strain
relations with US allies in Europe who
say they are standing by the agreement
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
good morning good morning
Iran says it will remain in the deal
along with our European allies who have
expressed regret over this announcement
the US will impose strict sanctions and
even consider new penalties the United
States no longer makes empty threats
president Trump followed through on his
long-held campaign promise to pull out
of the Accord saying Iran's pledge to
cease development of a nuclear weapon
was a lie in just a short period of time
the world's leading state sponsor of
terror will be on the cusp of acquiring
the world's most dangerous weapons the
2015 deal froze Iran's nuclear program
in exchange for lifting punitive
sanctions against Tehran a memorandum
signed by the president Tuesday would
reinstate many of those sanctions any
nation that helps Iran in its quest for
nuclear weapons could also be strongly
sanctioned under the financial sanctions
European companies will have between 90
and 180 days to wind down their
operations in Iran the oil sanctions
will require European and Asian
countries to reduce their imports from
Iran and licenses for Boeing and Airbus
to sell passenger jets to Iran will be
revoked costing the companies billions
of dollars I think the decision that
they took makes war more likely makes an
Iranian bomb more likely and makes the
United States less safe Jake Sullivan
who helped craft the agreement under
President Obama believes the Trump
administration is trying to destabilize
the regime what I'm worried about is the
ultimate goal here is actually some form
of regime change and that's a return to
an old playbook that we haven't
scene work out so well before White
House officials believe that abandoning
the deal establishes a position of
strength for the US with implications
not just for Iran but also for North
Korea sending a message that the United
States will not accept inadequate deals
John Paula
Thanks